travailler un boulon soir mon frère jean
seule la zone pour l'emploi relais rôle
tant que d'ailleurs certainement et aux
idées apprécié de ses meilleurs jours
d'itt west a pas pris ton texte qu'on
s'organise et moi je fais que du beco
génitales était déjà plein de choses à
faire à manger j'ai un père est né en
béton c'est dommage non mais dis donc
c'est fou quand même
j'y crois pas un t'as pas de morale
talaga la magnum était coincée du cul à
audi
t'as pas de morale talaga la magnum
était coincée du cul
hop hop
si tu veux je te dirai c'est sans tabou
m
mieux un donneur non stéphane delage ans
de sable et mon collègue
attendez ça c'est votre prénom stéphane
oui non c'est martel s'était pas de
marquer lé de lagence de sable et des
collègues
attendez attendez bon va falloir que je
ne va falloir que je recommence tout
temps des abats voilà bon ben c'est un
bogey tandis il va falloir que je
redémarre
bon bah c'est justement face à bah voilà
là c'est boguey c'est beau gachi boguey
a pas beaucoup ont dit buggé oui c'est
ce que je dis boga boga boga boga oui
mais on dit bugs comme bugs bunny oui
bogey et vous êtes bogué vous ces bugs
un ordinateur bugs
les frères bogdanoff bugs mais bon bogut
le la bouche est plus fermé bug c'est
l'anglais beau eu beau le bo beug beug à
aulas est ok
ah non mais je peux plus les prendre la
main vous préviens ça comme un peu véro
véronique fournier quoi vous savez il
vous adore les enfants et les enfants
pataugent tout le temps c'est fou de
toutes les nounous qu'ils ont et vous
êtes leur préférée c'est bien simple
d'ailleurs j'y pense c'est bête parce
qu'en fait il vous avait prévenu
peut-être la dernière fois qu'il me voit
comme voulait plus d'eux eh ben ils vont
vous le faire tout de suite
allez les enfants de 3 dans son
deux-pièces bien décorée elle me gardait
l'hiver était et nous faisait plein de
bisous nous elle gardait toute la
semaine et c'est tant mieux tellement en
laine fin des zones libres a toujours de
lewa maman n'a plus d'argent
adieu mon enfance je vienne mais bon ça
va ça va hein c'est bon je voulais pas
réglé la semaine prochaine sans merci du
fond du coeur
attendez attendez attendez là il ya une
erreur on est fonctionnaire peut pas
être licencié ouais bah non ban ou alors
on est fonctionnaire non n'est pas
fonctionnaire non écoute cathy je
travaille à l'agencé pour l'emploi
depuis dix ans je suis fonctionnaire je
travaille agence pôle emploi mais tu es
pas on n'est pas fonctionnaire non non
pas faux si on ne fonctionne elle rend
les femmes et enfants ont trouvé un
autre emploi on est fonctionnaire
enfin pas si on a employé on est
employeur regardant les statuts sais pas
c'est pas dans les statuts on est désolé
comme les autres on peut admirer comme
tout le monde on n'est rien à la société
tav a compris j'ai toujours voulu
fonctionner de la journée on traite
d'enculé de fonctionnaires tu as fini
par le croire
c'est quand même dommage on est là je
connais ta situation oppressante tu
connais la mienne
un petit peu bête on est et on va pas
rester malheureux chacun de notre côté
alors qu'on allait tous les deux les
organes qu'il faut pour se donner du
plaisir non pas pendant que le pape est
en feu depuis la collègue
oui enfin on est des collègues m'ont et
aussi de me faire un nom mais dis donc
c'est fou quand même
j'y crois pas un papa de mort halte à la
gueule à magnum était coincée du cul tu
vois dans un autre monde dans tout ça
bats toi et moi on aurait pu la trame
frères et soeurs
t'as pas vu mon slip
nouvelle vous n'êtes plus demandeurs
d'emploi n'arrive pas mac tu as lisez
pas au téléphone votre cerveau ne
fonctionne pas à vous toi vous toi toi
toi même vous dis toi j'ai pas dis toi
j'ai dis toi même et elle vous demande
de dire 3 3 comme de plus en plus et
c'est ce que je dis poids j'admets que
sur le 2 vous seriez plus à l'est mais
bon 3 c3
c'est pas toi vous n'aimez pas les noix
au contraire j'adore tout ce qu'il faut
c'est que raciste raciste connard
je
faire pour vous en sortir c'est l'une
des terreurs trouver quelque chose
plutôt innovant peut pas vous n'êtes pas
grave c'est rien c'est quoi votre petit
nid j'adore ce prénom martin à la
montagne martine à la plage
oui aussi partenaire la ferme tout à
fait je vais leur empire moi même mon
petit dossier tout le monde croit martin
qui l'a fait c'est quoi le petit mot de
passe par steam et minette comme mayotte
c'est joli ça vous avez une petite
chatte martin